as you can see I have a search page open
on my phone let's go to timeline and
record a trace okay now let's take a
look at what we have here first notice
that we see an event for the HTML
request then the server responds and we
get the response event from there the
HTML is streaming in and the parser is
processing each chunk by following the
same steps we just described its
organizing the data converting tokens
into nodes and building a Dom tree nice
so the timeline gives us a pretty
low-level view into what the browser is
doing as it loads the page yes exactly
and it can be a bit overwhelming at
first there's a lot of different events
in here but don't worry we're gonna
cover most of them that's it I think
it's a good idea for you to just try and
record a few different traces on on your
own pick a couple of favorite sites
record a few traces so you can spot some
interesting patterns once you're done
click this checkbox to hit continue